a multi-million dollar drug bust just
outside of las vegas 11 million dollars
worth of narcotics taken during an
operation along i-15 near moapa victoria
saha details what was discovered and the
impact those drugs are having locally
11.7 million dollars that's the street
value of the illegal drugs police took
off the streets during their seven day
drug bust 57 vehicles were searched
leading law enforcement to find 2 100
pounds of narcotics including marijuana
fentanyl and cocaine nevada state police
say they found 72 large bags of
marijuana in a rental truck that was
pulled over two suspects were arrested
and charged with trafficking fentanyl
has been a huge concern for law
enforcement given how strong the drug is
earlier this month our 8 news now i-team
went undercover with agents from the
drug enforcement administration as they
worked to crack down drug deals
involving fentanyl some of it comes from
mexico others are made right here in the
valley if the doctor didn't prescribe it
to you
don't take it it's just you're gambling
with your life and it's just not a
it's not a fun game you know to say oh
let's see what this does see how i feel
because you're probably going to die in
2021 226 people died from a fentanyl
overdose in clark county according to
southern nevada health district six of
those deaths were children under the age
of 18.
in 2020 the health district recorded 209
deaths involving fentanyl nine of them
were children that year and in february
a middle schooler at sedway reportedly
died after taking fentanyl pills that
were found on school grounds victoria
zaha live local now